[Music]
[Applause]
went to Seven Pro blls five-time First
Team all pro he is the former CBS sports
analyst and reporter he co-host one B
one bills live that airs weekdays from 1
to three and uh he also handles postgame
duties for the team what was it like uh
Steve post game in the locker room for
the
bills I'm thinking it's pretty
excruciating yeah uh this this is a game
that you know you you got to feel like
if you're a build that you absolutely
gift wrap and tied a bow on for the
Broncos to give away a game like that uh
particularly at the end where not only
had you played and turned the ball over
M your minus three on the turnovers in
the first half alone uh you're still
only trailing by a touchdown come back
finally give yourself a lead with two
minutes to go with the defense that has
been played really well even though they
were been
depleted and then then to have a miss a
field goal to win it only to have 12 men
on the field it's I think it's
excruciating and embarrassing a little
bit um yeah it's it's definitely a dark
dark Tuesday in Buffalo after a Monday
night game no question about it okay can
you pinpoint what's the
problem yeah no I I can't uh there have
been a couple of weeks there was a
stretch early in the first month of the
Season where this team was lights out
you know hanging 37 on the Raiders 38 on
Washington and then hanging 48 on a
Dolphins team that was three in one
coming in you know I mean they they
really seem like they had it now all of
a sudden you're right the problem seems
to
be a little bit esoteric you know maybe
it's one maybe it's a combination of
things maybe it's something different
every week but obviously something's
wrong with the recipe uh whatever the
ingredients are you got too much of this
and too little of that it seems like
they've got the recipes in the cupboard
somewhere and they just can't figure out
the mix um Josh Allen seems to be
regressing to where he was 2018 turning
it over too much uh certainly he's uh
and c and one thing that's been
disconcerting is they come out of these
games and they're turning it over I mean
right away I mean right out of the gate
in three games this this year they've
turned it over on the first series
couple of games on the first offensive
play so obviously that is not a recipe
for success but I think if you're going
to if you're going to put it at the feet
of one thing it's been the turnover
overs more than
anything I made this comparison earlier
in the show you played in the Brett fav
era I I do see some Brett Favre Josh
Allen similarities there wanting to make
the play Brett was a gunslinger I don't
know if Josh is labeled a gunslinger but
you know always willing to try to make
the big play sometime to the detriment
of their team is that a fair comparison
oh I think so I think Josh has been
labeled even by some of the people that
have played in postgame comments teams
have said yeah we we see a lot of arm
arrogance in Josh Allen you know we know
he's going to try and make a throw
nobody else is going to try and make and
let face it I mean it's awesome when he
does it and pulls it off and he does it
once or twice a game and almost every
game but lately he's been trying a
little too much and been trying you know
some of the same shots this you know the
shot to the Deep the Deep throw to the
sideline on a whole shot on a cover two
he tries that and he'll hit it more than
anybody but he throws more interceptions
there than anybody because that
underneath receiver the underneath
defensive back sloughs off and gets back
into the throwing Lane a little faster
than uh Josh
anticipates uh we've seen some
outstanding catches made in that spot
we've seen multiple interceptions being
thrown there so teams are starting to
get a handle that Josh is g goingon to
try and throw it if you can get in there
so a little bit of that and then we've
also got places where early in games
Josh will throw it to a guy and he'll
put some heat on it to get into a tight
window and it turns into a volleyball
match the guy comes off the guy's hands
and it turns into an interception we saw
that last night with Gabe Davis on the
second series of the game so you you
come out of the gate turn it over twice
in a game against the Denver Broncos all
of a sudden they're way in it in a game
where maybe otherwise they might be a
little overmatched and they end up
pulling it out at the end you we're
talking to Steve Tasker former Buffalo
Bills All Pro uh give me best case
scenario for this team realistic best
case scenario the rest of the season got
to go I mean realistically they got to
go I'm thinking five and two down the
stretch in the last eight seven games
eight games um and they've got the
Chiefs the Eagles the Cowboys the
Chargers the Jets Patriots and
Dolphins they got a first place schedule
and now they've done you know the first
you know
Dan when you find yourself in a hole the
first thing you got to do is stop
digging you know they haven't done that
yet so wow they gota they got to go you
know six and two maybe five and three
over the last eight games they got left
or last seven games they got left five-
two uh to have a shot to really get in
now if they beat the Patriots Dolphins
and jets they got a shot at the division
title if they can win a couple of those
other games but uh the best case
scenario is if they find some way to
claw and kick and scratch to get in even
as a seventh wild card there's there's
enough horses in the room to make a run
like they did in weeks two three and
four um they should get Von Miller
healthier and healthier and healthier
there's a chance dayquon Jones could get
back on the field um there's a chance
they'll get healthier and they'll have
guys like rasul Douglas get more
acclimated into the into the equation be
a CB one or CB2 here so they got a
chance to get back Health your Micah
Hyde get back on the field so they got a
chance to get healthier down the stretch
and they do have the ingredients in the
cupboard I think to put a run together
no question but that now the question
isn't how are they going to look when
they get to the playoffs can they get
over that hump the question is can they
get there and then when they do find
what they were so good at in the first
month of the season it's a tall order
you know it's a long
season but they gota they got to find a
way to get in and then put a run
together that's best case scenario they
got to go five- two down those last
seven games with The Gauntlet of a
schedule if the bills don't make the
playoffs yeah if they don't make the
playoffs you it's interesting it's hard
to and I know this too it's hard to
defend you know what's going on even
with the coaching staff and the players
after a game like last night but this is
still a team that's really difficult to
beat the times you see him lose games
are through ways that are unsustainable
you don't get a missed field goal in 12
men on the field to beat this you know
without beating this team last year the
the same thing with the Minnesota loss
last year they had three gam Stoppers
and all three of them go
catastrophically against the bills um
the the the narrative around Buffalo now
is they're looking back there's a 13-
second game that game there's a hail
Murray uh there's the Minnesota game as
I mentioned the overtime game in Tampa
Bay all these losses are all by single
digits they're through some quirky weird
circum stance that somehow the team
pulls out a victory and that's the
personality of the bills
losses their wins are convincing and
they have the
horses but if you go don't go to the
playoffs this year and you look at how
they've lost it does seem to be
something in that recipe that is not
allowing them to get over the hump you
know you got names like now Marty
Schottenheimer and Marvin Lewis being
compared to Shawn McDermot as a guy who
builds a great culture great great
system but they're not good enough to
get over the top Tony dunie the same
thing when he was in Tampa Bay before he
got to Indianapolis um you know there's
been other coaches like that
um Andy Reid same thing he was in Philly
could never get over the hump he was a
great good coach never a great coach
well now we've seen him take that next
step that's where Shawn McDermot and his
staff seemed to be on the cusp of being
good enough to put together a really
competitive team but something's missing
when they get to the Pinnacle great to
talk to you again Steve thanks for
joining us great seeing you Dan thanks
for having me on Steve Tasker five-time
First Team all pro special team seven
time Pro Bowl selection and works for uh
the Buffalo Bills